I can't believe you guys put together a party for me.
What do you mean?
Did you think we were just going to let you leave without a proper goodbye?
This was so nice of you. I'll never forget you guys.
The same is true for us.
It's been great having you here with us.
It's been great being here.
I promise I will keep in touch with you all.
So will we.
We're also going to find a way to get you back here again!
That would be great. I'll be back someday, I know it.
So what's the first thing you're going to do when you get home?
Well, my family is picking me up at the airport.
I guess we'll all go out for a nice dinner together.
I bet they're going to be really happy to see you again!
Not as happy as I'm going to be to see them!